deux hommes neuf femmes vont se lancer
dans la campagne pour les élections
législatives sous la bannière de la
république en marche
parmi eux parmi ceux qui ont été
désignés par dont on retrouve didier
baichère conseiller municipal de
versailles aurore bergé tranche
transfuge du parti les républicains est
élu dans la commune de magny les hameaux
ou encore michel de vaucouleurs issus du
modem avec un mandat municipal à poissy
pour le moment aucun candidat dans la 9e
circonscription
les autres candidats sont issus de la
société civile et du monde associatif
c'est aussi hâtif pardon je vous propose
d'écouter asys françois n'diaye
coordinateur du mouvement dans les
yvelines
nous aurons un maillage et un
accompagnement suffisant pour qu'il soit
intégré dans un groupe et dans une
structure qui soit suffisamment
structurée pour qu'ils puissent
bénéficier de tout tout tout les
ressources tous les outils nécessaires
pour un pouvoir faire campagne comme il
faut et par exemple pour ma part dans
les yvelines
je serai là la tête de liste entre
guillemets si on peut appeler ça comme
ça je ne serai pas candidat dans aucune
circonscription mais je serai candidat
pour toutes les circonscriptions pour
accompagner mon candidat justement à ce
que la campagne qu'ils auront à faire